je voulais prendre un petit moment pour
vous remercier pour vous dire ô combien
j'ai été heureux de voir tous vos
messages au début du confinement et
volante ou le confinement
je vous ai demandé de m'envoyer vos
vidéos pour partager votre quotidien
savoir comment ça se passait chez vous
vous avez été extrêmement nombreux à
envoyer votre contribution et ça m'a
fait vraiment chaud au coeur j'ai donc
le plaisir de le partager
je voulais vraiment vous remercier
aujourd'hui en france en tout cas ont
des consignes on va attaquer une
nouvelle étape
j'espère que ça se passera bien j'espère
que vous allez bien justement pour
pouvoir tourner cette première page d'un
confinement ont relativement commun de
deux mois eh bien je voulais vous
remercier et pouvoir diffuser les vidéos
vous me renvoyez que je n'ai pas encore
eu l'occasion ou l'opportunité diffusé
donc encore une fois un grand merci à
vous car sur vous et voici les dernières
vidéos j'ai pas pu diffuser salut
aurélien je m'appelle samuel j'ai 21 ans
je suis pas loin de lyon pour ma part
tout va bien ma famille tout va bien
j'espère que de ton côté c'est pareil
j'espère que le coroner virus ismail a
indiqué rapidement parce que la fesci
brillamment de victimes j'ai prévu un
voyage en suède ans au mois de juin pour
aller voir ce système faut danser la
nommer rêves de te les voir étant donné
que je vais moi même d origine
arménienne et que tous les membres du
groupe ont des origines arméniennes
ce serait bête que je les loue pas cool
ne sommes donc là actuellement je suis
dans ma voiture je suis en pause
je reprends je reprends dans quelques
minutes l'entreprise va fermer ce soir
pour manque de clients il faut que tout
le monde reste le maximum de temps
possible chez eux ne pas trop sortir à
part en cas de nécessité bien sûr ça
permettrait de freiner le virus
et au passage la petite vidéo que je
suis en train de faire je suis en train
de tourner avec le dj s 80 donc tu l'a
testé et c'est d'ailleurs toi qui m'a
convaincu de lâcheté donc je voulais
acheter et j'en suis très content
entretien continu ce que tu fais tu es
comme ça je t'admire beaucoup tu fais du
très bonne vidéo et puis sur ce ballon
n'arrive à deux minutes du coup je vais
devoir couper et ben je te souhaite une
bonne continuation et une bonne journée
salut bonjour monsieur re jeu
passement de temps qu'en filmant comme
tout le monde et puis je voulais vous
montrer un peu comment j'ai passé mon
confinement ça c'est un peu chez moi
voila voila je m'occupe de ma petite
bête
voilà toute mimi qu'est-ce que je suis
de mes journées
jean tablettes sous android en encre à
un encre électronique a qui me permet de
lire beaucoup de livres sur une seule
charge très très très pratique du fou et
puis je passe mon temps à faire le
ménage et la cuisine est aussi et depuis
pas longtemps j'ai un coup quéau connect
qui franchement ce moment est super
sympa bonjour à tous à lui monsieur
grrrr je m'appelle natrium et bienvenue
dans mon espace de télétravail j'ai la
chance de bien en sortir puisque déjà
avant le confinement je travaillais déjà
à domicile je suis vidéaste dans le
monde de la tête également et à côté de
ça je développe ma propre chaîne youtube
qui parle de teck évidemment donc tout
se passe juste ici sur ce bureau qui est
juste derrière moi et qui est mon banc
de montage non décor est également mon
ordinateur de tous les jours tout ce
setup se situe à exactement cinquante
centimètres d'un canapé vie donc je
pense que je suis la personne la plus
rapide sur terre à me rendre au boulot
le matin il suffit de lever du lit et de
me rasseoir sur cette chaise et ça y est
j'y suis juste à la gauche
il y à une porte derrière cette porte il
y a le set up de ma copine qui est
graphiste freelance on a déplacé tout
son matériel de paris jusqu ici en
sécurité pour qu'elles puissent
travailler avec moi dans de bonnes
conditions l'idée étant de limiter nos
déplacements au maximum et je profite de
cette petite apparition sur la chaîne de
monsieur greu pour vous demander s'il
vous plaît de les respecter vous aussi
restez chez vous restez chez vous
regardez les vidéos de la chaîne de
monsieur drevet vous aurez de quoi faire
et d'ailleurs en parlant de lui je vous
laisse avec sa vidéo
merci à tous et à bientôt du coup je
vais vous dire qu'est ce que je fais
pendant ce confinement je range ma
chambre je me détends je travaille un
peu pour ma formation de ces apps et
cuisine
on finir je voulais vous dire que moi je
m'appelle thomas j'ai 18 ans merci
encore pour vos vidéos monsieur greu
vous êtes au top et bon courage à tous
bonjour monsieur un peu bizarre hein
comme intro je fais un peu de chants de
gorge c'est pour ça donc moi le
confinement franchement c'est tranquille
parce que ça à faire quelques années que
je me dis que monde y va partir en
vrille total donc j'ai une maison au
milieu des bois
je suis vraiment tranquille des hectares
de bois et de champs où je peux faire ce
que je veux rivière tranquille
je fais aussi de la composition de
musique donc avec du chant de gorge
j'ai une chaîne qui s'appelle gomorrhe
prod où je fais du test matériel et je
donne aussi beaucoup de conseils pour le
tournage de clip de courts métrages des
petites astuces
le choix des objectifs des appareils
tournée avec enfin des tests comme en
tournée avec un smartphone
gopro dslr va pas mal d'astuces et là je
vais réaliser un court métrage avec tous
mes abonnés donc venez vous abonner à ma
chaîne parce que on va tout faire
ensemble de l'écriture du scénario au
tournage à la composition de musique à
la prise de son fatou de a à z
donc franchement si vous faites chez à
mourir chez vous eh bien venez m'aider à
réaliser
le court métrage à les mecs salut à la
prochaine salut aurélien salut à tous
mes atouts se levait déjà merci à toi de
nous ouvrir ta chaîne youtube par
rapport à ce confinement que l'on subit
toutes et tous belmont côté j'avoue j'ai
un petit peu de chance puisque
confinement je vis tout le temps à cause
de maladie tous sortent ou hiver 1
voilà et puis aussi mais le travail que
adopté depuis quelques années maintenant
puisque je suis présentateur météo pour
une radio fm
mon département de la dordogne et puis
aussi pour une page facebook un petit
peu de pub
l'acca météo de thomas k k comme la
lettre là car météo de ton mac a
d'ailleurs venez toutes et tous c'est
ouvert une météo fiable pour toute la
france
c'est ici que ça se passe et puis qu'est
ce que je voulais dire également v
franchement aussi comment je passe mes
journées hors travail mais il ya une
scène youtube d'un youtuber qui est
vraiment pas mal
je pense qu'on le connaît et que
beaucoup le connaissent il s'appelle le
seconde 1
voilà et moi qui suis fan de high tech
d'ailleurs je pense que ça peut
peut-être se voir étant donné que voilà
dans la pièce je peux changer les
couleurs à volonté grâce au film dessous
franchement ça c'est génial quelle belle
invention est handicapé je peux me
débrouiller tout seul s'il veut changer
les lumières et c'est aussi grâce un
certain monsieur breux que j'ai
découvrir ceux ci allait bien sûr se
très bonne journée merci encore à toi on
revient et à très bientôt
by coco sucrés c'est nasser je suis
compris au sud depuis le congrès son
épouse ou son poids de l'amour et je
voulais des polémiques afrique des
méfaits de la comparaison des grenats
tête avec les grenats d'esprit 2020 mr
d'apprendre le bruit et la technologie
embarquée par rapport à la technologie
d'existence
ainsi voici donc voilà c'est mon pseudo
bien sur youtube mais ce ballet vous
abonner à checker mais moi je pense
honnêtement qu'il voudrait remercier les
youtuber bien sûr remercié les
infirmiers et le personnel les ehpad
informaticiens tout le monde mais
également les youtuber il se donne et
nous au club neuf journées donc merci a
toi monsieur croix est-ce que sans vous
on serait bien plus dur et pour ceux qui
se demandent pourquoi je choque c'est
parce que je tourne la nuit par le bruit
cette vidéo la nuit j'ai pas envie de
crier vous savez une petite soeur à smr
détente
pourtant le confinement avaient dû bien
voilà donc voila j'aimerais je remercie
beaucoup les youtuber qui font des
vidéos dans ce conflit de moi et qu'ils
occupent la journée dans le mercy et on
pense à vous aux atours
restez chez vous